and this is a fox news alert now on that
900 billion coronavirus aid package now
heading to president trump's desk for
his signature
the package provides 600 direct payments
to the american people
and extended unemployment benefits but
the massive bill
did not escape harsh criticism from some
lawmakers 59 of them
nearly all republicans did not vote for
that bill
one of them joins us now texas
republican congressman brian babin
congressman good morning
welcome why why did you cast a no vote
uh it was a no-brainer for me there's
certainly some good stuff in there but
the process
this is not the way our government is
supposed to be working
the process was a complete failure and
it is a disgrace to the american
taxpayer the bill was
uh nearly 6 000 pages long it's easily
one of the largest bills ever passed in
congress
in fact it was so big that the printing
presses
broke down at the capitol uh and the
computers crashed and uh so that further
delayed our ability to even actually
see the text and they gave us just a
matter of a few hours
to read 6000 pages no amendments were
allowed
no committee work for the final product
just a handful of members
and their staffs who gathered in secret
to really write a 2.3
trillion dollar bill and the rest of us
could just take or leave it
and to do so in less than four hours i
believe it was it was irresponsible
to my constituents and the rest of the
american taxpayers
and uh to vote on something that of that
magnitude and not know the details of it
congressman as
as we all know democrats blame
republicans for holding this up
republicans blame democrats for
not getting this done as lindsey graham
said back in july
how did we get to this point i mean we
are
we're almost 10 months into this
pandemic
well you know i'm gonna of course anyone
who's on the other side of the aisle
watching this program might say yeah
well he's just blaming the democrats but
uh listen sandra miss pelosi
and her team had every opportunity
uh in fact in excess of 40 times we
tried to get uh ppp
uh passed and uh and authorized and
there was 137
billion dollars still sitting there uh
and we couldn't touch it because she
wouldn't deal
and so now and now we have but it was
done at the last minute
behind closed doors and as i said uh a
second ago
that's not the way to run a railroad and
i just didn't feel like it was a
responsible thing for me to do to vote
for that
uh and uh and vote on something that i
hadn't read you can't read
6 000 pages you can't even read a
synopsis of it
uh you know in just a matter of of the
time that they had given us
uh and i had i had uh actually made uh
requests to have certain items put into
it some of them made it early on
uh but some of them were not they they
shut the door and had a closed
operation where you could not you
couldn't get a uh you couldn't get
any amendments into it congressman as
far as what's in the bill we could do
our best to show our viewers what
what we know so far as far as dollar
amounts for vaccine distribution
69 billion dollars 22 billion to states
for testing and tracing
7 billion for broadband accesses in the
bill 45 billion for transportation and
transit agencies
rental assistance when it comes to
vaccine distribution rental assistance
obviously the 600 that's going to uh the
american people that so badly need it
do you agree that this will go to some
degree to helping struggling americans
absolutely absolutely there will there
was some good stuff in this bill
but there was also uh climate change
there was
uh uh a reduction of for for ice funding
uh you know we
we've got we've got a wide-open southern
border that is
that the president has done an amazing
job trying to control without uh without
any congressional help and to to cut ice
you know by uh 431 million it's just
simply not a good thing there's also
some gun control in there
background checks uh money for that
there were some things in there that
were good there was
things that were bad but the pro the
overall process
of the way it was passed the way it was
done the magnitude of it
and no time to to really study it was
what made me
decide to vote against it and you cast
your vote note
and you are here to talk about it this
morning congressman uh we know that that
is headed to the president's desk he's
expected to sign it this morning we'll
be watching for that
congressman appreciate your time this
morning thank you